we're gonna review some hot quarterbacks
I love football I love football - this
is so exciting
they're gonna fall guy I got a fall guy
not really I know absolutely nothing
about the NFL I'm a huge fan get my
fantasy football lineup it's just hot
dudes hey Tony Romo he's fun man I'm
just the thing are I look like what he
looks like a little team - yeah I mean
for the most part he doesn't win at all
I feel bad for Cowboys fans because he's
such a loser
maybe that's why girls like him cuz he's
like kind of broken I could see people
saying hot but I'm definitely going to
say not okay not mister Cam Newton ah hi
I can be the hottie he's a stud stunner
that's strong neck and that strong
jawline it's the dimples it's the
dimples I would marry him so fast he's
so hot that's like been one of those
guys where I like ask my girlfriend like
do you think he's hot he'll be like yes
I'm like thank you because he is
he remains hot playing in the NFL's
ugliest uniforms and he's so fast he's
fast he does like the little Superman
thing when he scores a touchdown he
probably does that when he scores
another time cam might be the hottest
person ever funny NFL over all very odd
he's handsome really handsome no it
looks confused all the time I think he's
hot I like this it was a good-looking
dude right here he's super classy he's a
great guy but uh you know at the end of
the time you're still trying to give it
the beast mode you don't want someone
that's gonna metaphorically get picked
off at the one-yard line Pete Carroll Oh
like he's like he looks like a player
like he looks like he might sleep with
two of my friends maybe I disagree
really he looks like totally monogamous
nobody throws a sexier deep ball than
this guy right here Russell Wilson
dreamboat I like this guy here's the
strong nose Aaron Rodgers is funny
my girlfriend adores this guy
all-american hunk
yeah he's definitely hunky look at those
pretty blue she has a mustache sometime
sometime I can't grow a mustache no
overall hot Rutter's looks like the guy
that will date your sister need to prove
of him I don't have anybody
right there ah Matthew Stafford he looks
like a potato at the State Fair I'd
smash k-pot he just looks like he hangs
out at the carnival he uses the phrase I
tell you what Salford looks like the guy
that you'd run into at a college party
that's like extra sweaty for no reason
he looks like how he is as a quarterback
you know like fragile easily injured
tries to go downtown all the time not
hot not hot if he had Megatron maybe Jay
Cutler oh I thought it was Tom Cruise
for a second looked like it was another
football game he have beautiful eyes
he's a good-looking dude but he's a
massive douche I feel bad for Bears fans
this guy's fine and after you're done
you're gonna smoke a pack of cigarettes
in bed why does he look different than
that he doesn't look like a football
player yeah he doesn't even though he's
such a dad I also wouldn't want to let
him near my kids I mean he looks like
the really hot guy you went to high
school with but you bump into 15 years
later and you're like oh like last call
at a bar this is what you're gonna have
to go home with the Cutler special over
oh sorry big brother vs. brother Manning
brother well well well great you want to
save on tape one two three